[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
distribution des plis électoraux lors
des scrutins de juin 2021
chronique d'un dysfonctionnement
jeudi 22 juillet françois noël buffet a
présenté à la presse les conclusions de
la mission d'information sur les
dysfonctionnements constatés lors des
élections départementales et régionales
de juin 2021
depuis 2020 la société adrexo était
chargée de la distribution d'une partie
des plis électoraux avec la poste
lors des élections départementales et
régionales de juin 2021 adrexo n'a pas
été à la hauteur de l'enjeu
des milliers de foyers français n'ont
pas reçu à temps la propagande
électorale
le sénat a créé une mission
d'information afin de faire la lumière
sur les défauts de l'organisation
logistique des opérations électorales et
les responsabilités des acteurs
impliqués
installé au sein de la commission des
lois celle ci a été dotée des pouvoirs
d'une commission d' enquête
le 23 juin la mission entendait gérald
darmanin responsable en tant que
ministre de l'intérieur du déroulement
des opérations électorales
celui ci a reconnu les
dysfonctionnements
de l'aveu même des opérateurs
26,6 pour cent des électeurs n'ont reçu
aucune propagande pour les élections
départementales et 40,3 % pour les
élections régionales
cette proportion atteint même plus de
90% dans plusieurs départements
pour que ces défaillances ne se
reproduise pas la mission d'information
adressée 12 recommandations dont voici
quelques unes
la mission suggère de préciser et
d'uniformiser les consignes de
distribution a donné aux agents
elle recommande de ne pas exclure
l'attribution de tous les lots du marché
un même opérateur postal sans pour
autant le soustraire à toute mise en
concurrence
elle préconise aussi de permettre aux
électeurs qui en ferait la demande de ne
recevoir la propagande électorale que
sous format numérique
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]